The number one question I get from people who watch these light board videos is how do you learn to write backwards?
Well, as you can see, I can't.
You'll also notice I'm not left handed.
But what we do is a trick in the edit process, after the video has been recorded, is we flip.
And once we've done that, it looks right to the camera.
And I can still write the way I'm normally able to write.
Another thing that you see now is I'm not writing in the air.
I'm sure you assumed I wasn't, but now you can see what in fact it is.
I'm writing on a piece of glass.
In this glass, you don't see, because we zoom in and crop the edges.
So that's why you don't see that.
Also, you don't see the special lights that we have embedded around the edge of the glass,
which is what makes these special markers really pop and illuminate.
So those are the things that go into it.
And then ultimately, what you also don't see, is all the people, the big team, the global team, behind me that makes all of this possible.
We've got people who are directors, who direct the content, manage the content, develop that.
We've got recording specialists, we've got graphic artists.
We've got people who are editing all of this and putting it all together.
This really is a global effort to make all of this possible.
And now you know the secret to the light board.
Thanks for watching.
Please remember to like this video and subscribe to this channel so we can continue to bring you content that matters to you.